hey everyone welcome to our first hustle
chat I'm Brad Warburton I oversee the
editorial team at the hustle and I'm
joined today by several of my esteemed
colleagues who've been covering this
coronavirus crisis in doing such an
amazing job we've gotten really an
outpouring of positive feedback from our
audience from all you guys in recent
days and I just thought it'd be
interesting to take a little bit more of
a behind-the-scenes look to tell you a
little bit about how we've found the
stories and what we're working on going
forward and before we get started I
thought I'd just kind of introduce each
of you I'll start with you Mia you are
holed up out in San Francisco with a
couple of roommates including your
fiance and I'm curious about your
wedding plans and how this is this whole
moment has affected you yeah so we're on
I believe it's day 11 of
shelter-in-place in San Francisco yeah
it's going okay we have a nice backyard
so then just like taking my dog for runs
and hanging out in the backyard I'm feel
really grateful though that we do not
have a wedding date and it will stay
that way until this all passes seriously
that's smart Connor you went from sort
of San Francisco which was the epicenter
of the crisis for a while and moved
across the country to the now new
epicenter of the crisis the New York
City area
what's that been like um yeah I left San
Francisco twelve days ago right before
they called the shelter in place for San
Francisco and I came back in time for
them to call one in New York few days
later so I've been holed up with my two
younger siblings and my folks in New
Jersey so we've gotten terribly clovis
in the past couple weeks which has been
fun that's awesome playing a lot of card
games and stuff I think is what you said
right that's right it's nice Michael
you've also moved from the west coast
back to the East Coast but for different
reason you were your editorial intern
this semester and you were in college or
senior year and now you're back home
with your family what what's going on
with you yeah I'm in a very strange
place where my graduation a fish
Billy is not gonna happen but I am not
fully graduated I'm still doing like
zoom classes though I'm it's just a very
weird in-between space to be that I
think like myself and a lot of my are
stuck in or at home we're sort of still
in school we're sort of supposed to look
for jobs it's very odd
that's a strange time I feel sorry for
you that was like one of the best
moments in life was that last semester
of college Nick you and I are in the DC
area and you're basically DC's kind of
shut down right now right it is we're
all sheltering in place and and I've
basically been you know working from
home and trying not to move around too
much for like it's basically two weeks
for me now one of the things that is
helping me cope a little bit as
springtime this time of year is is
really nice in DC and spring is great I
think one thing that's a little odd is
we're sort of at peak cherry blossom
season here in DC but nobody can go out
to see them and they had to shut down
all the roads down on the mall to keep
people away which is a pretty surreal
thing to see this time here yeah here
yeah I mean I am in in the same spot I'm
just I've got I'm in a neighborhood
where there's lots of noises during the
day so please forgive me if I don't hit
mute fast enough on this call
whether it's leaf blowers across the
street or barking dog or teenager
screaming you might hear some of it so
anyway I wanted to sort of get us to
have a quick discussion about the things
that we've seen in in the last couple
weeks of our coverage and maybe I'll
start with you Nick you're you oversee
our daily email and you've kind of taken
a sweep of all the news that's happening
but in looking broadly we sort of asked
our audience what our stories and things
that have been pacted you you found
something that was really close to home
skin tell us about that yeah you know I
think there are two two themes that
we've talked a lot about in terms of
what we've done so far and what we want
to continue doing is we want to tell
stories of resilience in this moment
because people are facing really tough
times personally and if you are involved
in a business these are really
challenging times as well and pivots
where for a lot of people individually
and if you
are leading a business you might have
had to prove it overnight and one of the
businesses that I that I I spoke to
their founders maybe a week ago now they
had to do just that where they actually
open the business on on Valentine's Day
that weekend at February 14th and then
the pandemic set in and they had to
close up shop a month later and it was a
really interesting really interesting
story because they have a interested a
bill a unique niche and Brad I think you
can probably speak to this as somebody
who has a couple of kids there's it's
really challenging I think for new
parents to to have places where they can
go out and the whole family can have a
good time one of the things that the
founders talk to me a little bit about
is if you go out say to a brewery that's
the thing that's going to appeal to the
new parents but not to the kids or you
can go to an area where there might be
you know park where there's slides or
you go to an indoor spot where there
might be a ball pit and that's all for
the kids but there's not really a lot
for the parents so the idea here was
just sort of combine the two and the the
idea behind their business is they're
going to have all sorts of options and
ways to entertain young children but
they're also going to serve coffee and
beer and wine and smoothies and salads
and hopefully create a little bit more
of an experience that is that is
relevant for the whole family and one of
the things that was super interesting
since they're sort of in my backyard is
that you could tell right away that the
business was going to be a hit because I
remember hearing stories from friends
who live nearby like they had lions
wrapped around the building I think on
on opening weekend so they were super
successful and they said that they had
had on that first weekend like more than
700 people through the business on you
on one day and that opening weekend and
and then a month later they were
completely shut down and they overnight
had to pivot to entirely virtual
offerings where they're now doing you
know virtual dance classes and trying to
put together activity kits to keep kids
entertained if they're cooped up with
their families and their parents who
might be working from home and it really
the whole thing really changed overnight
and I think you know in speaking to them
the pivot to virtual was something they
had considered over the long term but
was something that they had to spin up
like in the course of 24 hours that's
pretty interesting
speaking of virtual pivots Connor you
talked to a company that does like they
do make it's a makeup business can you
tell us a little bit about the sparkle
bar and what you heard from them and how
they pivoted yeah of course it was one
of the interesting features of talking
to folks was we tried to cast a wide
enough net to get not only businesses
like the one Nick was just talking about
that are trying something fairly new but
also businesses like the sparkle bar
which is a makeup studio so doing
something that's been around for quite a
while this particular makeup Studios in
the Scottsdale area and it got closed
down about a week or so ago but before
that there was already a huge dip in the
number of people who are willing to come
into the studio because you obviously
are getting really close with other
people and there were concerns there so
we talked to the team over there and
Alex Bradbury who is the operator of the
studio showed me that even people who
are working in industries that seem kind
of inflexible like a makeup studio are
doing some pretty innovative things when
it comes to coming up with you know
teleconferencing ways of getting their
business done and in this particular
case the sparkle bar takes a lot of
pride in its relationships with its
customers and they work with the people
who come into their studio beforehand
and check up on them afterwards to make
sure that they got exactly what they
wanted they do a lot of work for special
events like weddings and stuff like that
and what they're at work doing right now
is making sure that they're able to
replicate that kind of one-to-one
personal touch over teleconference and
so they've already begun to do that they
bought themselves a little bit of wiggle
room with gift cards and some other kind
of cash flow tricks that a lot of small
businesses are trying and now they're
hard at work as an entire staff I think
there are 13 people under employ they're
shifting their entire business model so
that they can actually send someone
make up and work with them to you know
have kind of a styling session over
videoconference and then check in with
them afterwards to make sure well and
things like that they're very much
working as they go but it's pretty cool
to see how even an industry like that
was able to make this switch so you've
done you did another piece on this
company I think it's called snap bar
totally different circumstances in a
much sharper pivot which is probably one
of the more interesting ones I've heard
yeah snap bar was really cool um they're
a business that normally sells photo
booths for events and given that all
events for kind of the foreseeable
future are canceled they had to really
find an entirely new business model if
they were gonna keep all their employees
afloat and the way that they went about
doing that was actually something
entirely different than their existing
business and what they did was they're
based up in the Seattle Tacoma area and
Washington and they worked with a bunch
of local vendors to put together
direct-to-consumer boxes highlighting
soaps foodstuffs all kinds of local
Seattle goods from producers that
otherwise would have struggled to keep
their own lights on and they said hey we
have a customer service team we have a
sales staff let's use all of our you
know internal resources in terms of
these talented employees and have them
sell a completely different product and
then doing so you know hopefully we can
keep our lights on and you know keep
these other producers engaged and make
sure that their business is still moving
so they came up with this really cool
solution
I think it's available not just in
Seattle but in San Francisco and several
other cities and they're working on
expanding that very cool and and also
finding a way to keep the employees they
have they have like 40 people on staff
and various roles and so many people
right now in this moment have lost their
jobs just like yesterday what was the
news Nick like 3 plus million people
found unemployment claims which is one
of the largest if not the largest ever
pretty pretty amazing pivot for them
hopefully they can be successful so the
other one I found interesting was
Michael talked to this company called
think the Republican
and they're basically like a chain of
sushi restaurants in Ohio tell us the
story of what they're doing and how
other people can learn from that yeah
exactly so fusion there are 10 different
locations throughout the state of Ohio
and basically what happened with them is
Iowa was the early states who shut down
all non-essential business and so this
hat about two weeks ago and it totally
took fusion by surprise
there was no like warning from the
governor that is about to happen and so
the company truly just like pivoted in
three days to becoming basically like a
part-time grocer and the way they did
this is super interesting to me and it
involves like understanding the some of
the logistics of how supply chain work
in the US but basically there's a supply
chain for groups or labs for restaurants
and bars etc just because I have
different needs in terms of bulk orders
like what customers expect out of them
and what if you didn't realize is that
while grocery stores were sold out of
items like tofu which they had access to
London that was not because Aalto in the
Ohio area was hard to access it was
because groups or a specific supply
chain system didn't have enough tofu
whereas fusion because they use a
different supply chain could easily just
source that and the idea is that
obviously of course they would
originally source tofu like for their
meals that they would sell to people but
will it they realize that they could do
is they could just sell it as a grocery
store and so now Fusion will deliver
sushi to your home in Ohio it will also
deliver groceries and they've had a lot
of success doing that well I'm standing
at a standing desk right now it's a
fully standing desk which I love and I
was also intrigued to hear the story of
Deskmate I think is what it's called
right Nia they were struggling a couple
months ago and they've actually
benefited so we have some businesses in
this moment that have figured out that
this is a time when they can really
thrive so tell us a little bit of the
backstory of what happened with them and
what they've experienced
yeah so desk meet is a standing standing
desk company so they make these like
little portable cardboard standing desks
that you can flip up on your desktop
they're really inexpensive I think they
start at 30 euro or 30 pounds and they
were really struggling before
Cobin 19 they had some supply chain
issues that seemed to be unrelated to
all of this but their manufacturers shut
down and they basically couldn't fill
orders for a month because they couldn't
get their stock from their their
manufacturer and warehouse so they the
two co-founders is just the two of them
they were like okay we're going to sell
they found a buyer but the buyer ended
up backing out because of market
instability and I think this is
mid-february so kind of right before
Koba 19 I came to the world in an
intense way but the guys just rolled up
their sleeves and we're like okay we're
gonna try to we're gonna try to make
this work we actually now have this
great opportunity because so many
companies are trying to figure out how
to outfit their employees at home and
these desks I mean it seems like they
could have started this company right
now that the idea is so perfect for the
moment so their biggest issues right now
are that they just don't think that they
can make enough for the interest they're
getting so many orders they're getting
orders around the world especially in
expain in Italy and in the US so what
they're trying to do is find a
manufacturer that they can actually
produce the desks in the US to so they
don't have to they won't have to ship
overseas they want to ship everything
overseas but yeah they have an exciting
opportunity very cool so before we go I
wanted to just sort of tease some of the
things we're working on to help people
get you know get people excited about
things that we haven't works Mia you're
working on a piece about a straw company
that was about to launch a travel fork
and tell us a little bit about what
you're finding with them and what you're
planning to write yes
this company is called final and they're
they're new they started their business
in 2018 and their product is a final
it's called the final straw it's a
reusable stainless steel travel straw
they did super well they did five
million in revenue their first year kind
of they launched I'm in the midst of the
you know anti plastic straw craze and
they were working on launching a travel
for their supposed to launch it actually
on Earth Day but because of all this you
know like no one really wants to travel
for right now so they made like an
incredibly quick pivot to reusable
disinfecting wipes so it's basically
like these bamboo rags and you have this
cleaning tablet that you put in them you
can use them and then you throw the rags
in the in the dishwasher or sorry not in
the dishwasher in the laundry and then
you can you know put a new tab and then
they keep using them so I think that
kind of I think they obviously need a
need because if you guys have found an
Amazon recently you can't get
disinfecting wipes very very readily um
so awesome man send me some of those I
could use a bunch yeah same with you
Connor you've got this thing on this
company called I think it's called life
aid and or maybe it's yeah I think it's
coming out soon we've worked on it we
haven't we haven't published it yet but
tell us a little bit about that or
anything else you're working on this
year that's right yeah this company life
aid they're based in California they are
a beverage company that makes healthier
alternative drinks for athletes who
otherwise might be inclined to grab a
soda post-workout they've done quite
well they've been around since 2011 and
they actually you know like Mia
mentioned with some of these other
business she's been looking into they're
doing fairly well in the crisis they've
had a bunch of their distribution
channels just blow up on Amazon they've
been selling Walmart all their major
retail partners they've been kind of
blowing up
so that's been really great for them but
the company actually grew into its own
by partnering with a lot of local gyms
and all of those original partners have
since closed but life eight has made the
decision not to turn it back on those
original partners but rather to invest
the unexpectedly high revenue they've
been getting from Walmart and Target and
Amazon and create a bunch of partnership
and affiliate programs with these gyms
to help keep them open through the
crisis so it's a really cool example of
a kind of community business episode
where the way that the founders of Life
fade will tell you they would have
gotten to where they are today without
those original smaller partners and so
they feel a sense of pretty deep
obligation to them today when they're
going through a difficult time so it's a
pretty cool story of both how kind of
business distribution works and which
channels are rewarding who them right
now and also just how community can kind
of come together in moments like this
and help each other out
very neat I don't want to give away too
much on this yet Michael but we talked a
couple days ago about having you do a
piece on your experience as a graduating
senior now entering the crazy job market
and what you're seeing and what you're
feeling and experiencing anything you
want to tease on that story um not too
much yet but I do think that I already
know from anecdotal experience and from
talking to people so far is that like
what this moment means a lot just in
terms of like where people see
themselves in the future obviously and
especially just in terms of different
industries like for instance like people
have relied so much on service work as a
bridge into acting or something or into
these I guess funnels into these larger
like thick fuel and that goes for all
sorts of industries and so people are
definitely starting to rethink like
where they want ahead but I do think one
thing that I found personally to be
[Music]
kind of cathartic is this all these like
different face popped up like these
Facebook mean groups for people are just
sort of trying to make sense of this
moment through like very bad jokes and
actually like that has been somewhat
gingka said at the top like it's a it's
your place to be and I think especially
I feel this much more strongly than I am
too and good to know that there's at
least some like sort of communal
understanding about it even if that may
not make a difference in terms of actual
jobs well exactly
lastly I've thought I'd turn back to you
Nick we had this discussion this morning
about the long tail of the pandemic no
one obviously knows how soon any of this
stuff's going to end but we're starting
to think about some of the industries
that are gonna feel pain for a long time
is there any parting thoughts you want
to share about things we're looking at
or thinking about covering in that way
yeah I mean certainly I don't want to be
in the business of making predictions
because we're not even in the you know
the height of the pandemic here in the
US I think it's going to get a lot worse
before it gets better
but I think these are questions that
people are starting to think about and
I'm reminded of earlier this week there
was even a poll that went up on our
company slack that was sort of about
have your views on working from home
changed in light of what's happened in
the last couple of weeks and one of the
things that people were quick to point
out is that this is not normal working
from home yeah you know normally you can
you can actually leave your house and
you might go get dinner or you might do
something else in the middle of the day
but I think that's that sort of question
is a reflection of what people are going
to be asking in the coming months to
what extent is this pandemic going to
sort of turn the world of work inside
out and what are some of the long-term
impacts that that maybe we don't see
right yet but we're now starting to see
signs that this is going to change
certain industries permanently that's
definitely a thing that as I said we I
don't think any of us can be in the
business of making strong predictions
about but it's definitely something that
we're going to be watching watching for
and and trying to to tease out a few of
those themes in
coming weeks also what we've done really
well I think is we found as troubling
and difficult as this moment is for many
people to navigate we've found some
moments of levity that we can share so
we were going to continue to try to do
that whether that's hashtag some good
news in this mess that we're all in or
other things so keep your ideas coming
to us thanks for listening in on our
first little hustle chat today and look
forward to seeing you all soon
thanks everybody
[Music]